foreign
abusive marriage actually
um and I I've met another female and I'm
just struggling I I don't know if I
should let this develop or not
um if I'm ready for that
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
sure we talk about your mental health
your emotional health what's going on in
the world what's going on in your life
what's going on your marriages whatever
happens to be on your mind or in your
life or whatever I'm here for you give
me a call at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 the show is real people
going through real junk in their life
and I don't have all the answers but I
promise I'll sit with you promise I'll
sit with you or you can go to John
deloney.com ask
um don't forget you know this is my
favorite thing to ask but don't forget
to like and share and subscribe and hit
all the the algorithm buttons
um it really really makes a difference
when it comes to show rankings it makes
a huge difference on kicking this thing
up to the algorithms and there's
somebody right now who's in an abusive
relationship somebody who doesn't know
how to connect with their kid somebody
who's struggling with what the schools
are telling their child and they don't
know where to go and when you like or
subscribe to the show it kicks it up
into their YouTube feed or into their
podcast feed and they get a different
person perspective and so thank you so
much costs nothing but you really help
out a lot and last thing I'll ask you to
do is go to johndalene.com and pick up
building a non-anxious life we're still
in pre-sale it is breaking every record
we got around here and it's awesome I'm
super excited about it in fact I don't
even know what to say I'm kind of
speechless and you all know if you
listen to the show that is a rare thing
that I run out of words
um but I was just sitting on my front
porch the other night just staring off
into space I I just don't have the words
for it so I'm so grateful if you haven't
picked it up it's 20 bucks you get a
whole bunch of free stuff with it
um but building a non-anxious life and
on behalf of all of us let's just commit
to that can we commit to like not living
in the chaos anymore and that means we
have to give up some stuff that means we
have to maybe make some less money
um that means we're gonna maybe have one
or two less activities to do or whatever
let's just commit to building
non-anxious lives I promise the smoke
will clear I promise let's go out to
Ryan in Gainesville Florida what's up
Ryan
Dr deloney thank you for having me of
course man thank you for calling in what
up
um I'm having some guilt um I don't know
if I'm doing the right thing as far as
my situation goes okay hold on before
you tell me
I'm only
I tend to believe that guilt well no
okay I'm gonna interrupt you go ahead I
was gonna I was gonna
I've just been wrestling with something
just philosophical but this isn't the
time or place for my stuff so go ahead
you go with you go ahead Ryan
well I'm I'm a I'm a chronic overthinker
and I have anxiety uh depression
um and I just got out of a physically
abusive uh marriage actually
um and uh second marriage and divorced
two and a half months ago
um and I I've met uh another female and
I'm just struggling I I don't know if I
should
let this develop or not
um if I'm ready for that
or if it's the right thing to do in the
first place
two kids yeah with my first marriage
okay
um how long was your second year
nine months
yeah
well you just said yeah you judged your
that length of time I didn't what
happened man
she started
she started getting physically abusive
with me which she knew I've been in one
other relationship where that that has
been a problem
and she knew all about that I would
never you know I would never resort to
that and that
it is it got pretty bad and that that's
when I knew regardless of the length of
time and and I don't believe in I'm a
Christian I don't believe in divorce
um I don't I I I'm not believe it or not
I'm not the one who actually chose to
get divorced I chose to get separated
um because of the physical abuse and it
happened in front of my son one time uh
so I approached her about getting a
separate separating from her and then
her response was well I don't believe in
separation it's either we divorce or
yeah okay so I mean it sounds like
you're married to someone who is
struggling with a lot pretty immature
and
um
what is it about you that draws you to
volatile
abusive women
struggling to answer myself to be honest
with you I I don't know
do you like to help
um are you just a pretty stable secure
guy
you said you're anxious you struggle
with some anxiousness and so that almost
is like uh Fire and Fire coming together
right
I've always been an agreeable person I I
don't like conflict
um
I am stable I do you know I have three
jobs I I've worked I've done a lot of
things to better myself during that
I I was with my recent ex-wife three
years by the way so it was a nine month
marriage but we were together for three
years and I I worked on a lot she
pointed out a lot of things I needed
I bet she I bet she let you know loud
and clear what you screwed up on and you
needed to fix right and I and I did I
made a lot I made a lot of effort to
change and and I'm thankful for it
because I did better myself
um
but at the same time
all I asked for from her was to be loved
I I never asked her I didn't want to
change I don't I know I don't want
anything other than you know obviously
her temper but I I didn't ask her to
change anything but I I accepted her
challenge to change myself and
I changed a lot of things I did but once
she started becoming physical I I knew
right then and there I I had to get away
yeah
um
so maybe that's an unfair question just
to lob on my part
um but I think it's something worth
considering
and if you go back and look at some of
the previous relationships you've been
in where people were violent with you
and my guess is the other ones where
they weren't violent there was some
volatility there is that fair
yes sir yeah there were some ups and
downs and some whoa and some yikes
um and so I would I think an important
thing to do
would be to write down
four or five or ten
things that were common across those
relationships
how'd you feel
what did they say
what did
um when there was a well there's a
disagreement
how was there some commonality there
because that's going to help be your
compass for no matter how good it feels
how
how attracted you are to somebody
how funny she is or how alive she makes
you feel
that's going to be a good road map for
hey I've been down this road before
it's at least enough to get you to ask
some questions right
right and so when it comes to I get this
question a lot
um how long after I'm divorced should I
start dating how long should I I don't
have a I don't have a you need to wait
six months or four I don't have a thing
because a lot of marriages were done
five years before they actually get
divorced they were over for a long time
in some marriages like yours like hey I
just want to take a separation for 30
days and she's like well fine I file on
you and it's just over right and so some
of that is some smoke clearing
I think my general wisdom is
if you can't talk about your previous
relationship without your heartbeat
taking off on you you're probably not
ready
if you can't
walk through here's what happened
here's where what how where it was so
good and here's where it wasn't so good
and here's where we are now if you can't
do that you're probably not ready to
start dating
and I'll go one step further
um I think we get obsessive about
finding the next forever person
you have permission just to go have
friends man go hang out
you don't have to end up sleeping with
everybody you don't have to end up in a
romantic relationship with everybody you
can't just go have fun hang out
you know what I mean like there's a it's
hard once you're married it seems like
all right now we're back into the you
either go like I'll go play the field
bro that's dumb or
all right I gotta find the next to the
next I mean there's there's some Middle
Ground there see what I'm saying
yes sir I feel like my faith has allowed
me to change my viewpoint as far what
you just mentioned that's always
approached dating
that trap I put myself into but this
time after this second divorce I really
prayed about it I I've sought
um
counsel from my church and they've
they've they said exactly what you just
said just just
you just focus on myself and just let
you know God show me the way and well
but some of some of that language is
kind of you gotta be careful about that
great because it's like gosh it's gonna
he's just gonna put the person in front
I mean you gotta go out right I know
people who are still just sitting at
home waiting like nope I've been praying
and God's just gonna send them out and
it's like well dude you gotta leave your
house right so it's both and it's both
and
see what I'm saying right gotcha but I
don't think that means
I'm not gonna tell you if you've met
somebody that's kind and great and just
seems like a good human being to be
around I'm not gonna say like no you cut
that person off that's that would be
dumb on my part
I also think
you're oh for two on marriages right
yes sir so
um and my guess is you had some volatile
dating relationships before those
marriages are in between them is that
fair
yes sir so maybe before I get back in
the batter's box I am going to give a
hitting instructor and figure out what
I'm doing wrong with my swing
that makes a lot of sense and when
you're in the like when you do it that
way you're not worried about what the
pitcher's throwing you're worried about
your swing mechanics and I think I'm a
sports writer so you're you're talking
right to me there you go so you're not
throwing you're not worried about what
the pitcher's gonna throw
I'm worried about how my stance is and
how my feet are and how my hips turn and
how my you know you know all that stuff
on my wrist turned over so all that to
say is I would get somebody just to walk
through with you and a good counselor
could do that for you they could walk
back in time with you also a couple of
wise men that are 10 or 15 years older
than you that would just agree to have
coffee with you once a week
or once a month
that could be amazing and you could say
hey I've had this with women I clearly
I'm not good at dating or being married
can y'all help
and dudes love giving advice to each
other right
right but I think having some wisdom
there from some people who have been
there maybe talked to some folks who've
been divorced before and are in marriage
number two or are dating who have got
some wisdom on you that can walk you
through and say hey here's been my
experience here's what here's some
pitfalls that I fell into here's some
mistakes I made here's some things that
I I wish I'd done again and that can
just be some great great wisdom but I
think
you need to get to the root of
why do I think so little about Ryan that
I keep ending up in these
relationships where I am used as
the soil for somebody else to grow
why am I
always the gasoline for somebody else's
engine
because you've got more value in
relationships than that man
you're worth more to those relationships
than you just making sure
that the other person can chew you up
and spit you out
and I'll even go one step further
volatility in a relationship actually is
kind of fun
like fighting making up
hooking up like all it's fun like
there's some energy in there there's
there's the words I hear are alive
people say like I felt alive I felt
alive
and that's cool but I'll tell you you
know what also was cool warmth
laughter
fights
being silly
and I have found as I've gotten older
that seeking
aliveness inside of the Comfort instead
of trying to squeeze Comfort out of ah
chaos has been a much more sustainable
path for relationships and so I tell you
you know volatility you know Bonkers you
know yelling and screaming you know
punching and kicking I want you to
practice peace
I'm gonna send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book
um about this very thing
and it may be brand new to you man I'm
gonna challenge you to get with somebody
and y'all work through these steps how
do I create this life I map it out for
you in the book how to create a
non-anxious life and when I do that I'm
going to create some boundaries that
then these new relationships I'm just
not gonna cross
it's not gonna cross I'm gonna begin to
see chaos coming
I'm going to begin to feel my body
because it starts gearing up when things
get chaotic and volatile it knows it's
coming and I'm gonna just choose to say
hey thanks but no thanks I'm good
I want to get my kids I want to get
myself I want to get my future
patience kindness peace and laughter
just a much better way to live we'll be
right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Nicole back to Florida what's up Nicole
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
oh nothing just hanging out with my
five-month-old here whoa
yeah you know it's it's a good life it's
a good life well played well played
what's up
um okay so my question is how do my
husband and I best raise our sons to not
latch on to
when I've been diagnosed with OCD and I
also have anxiety welcome to the gang
dude yeah right you're the king party
isn't it what a fun Club to be a part of
right
um okay so how old are your kids you
have five month old and what else I got
five month old and an almost
two-year-old and I've been noticing with
the two-year-old that he is already so
uh my OCD is it's been called
religiosity or scrupulosity
um so it feels much more with like
um in my thoughts and my speech rather
than like organizing and stuff like that
yeah
um hold on when you get really really
really tired
yeah what's the physical manifestation
um and I think it's I grew up in a
pretty
um
I mean fairly religious Mennonite
um house and so it's I think it's based
around
worrying that I'm gonna sin and go to
hell like that's the
you know I mean I don't think about that
that's kind of a big consequence right
well yeah it is you know rather
life-changing yeah some people don't
want to get in car wrecks right so they
don't drive or they don't leave their
house you just don't want to be tortured
for eternity right exactly Fair exactly
fair to your poor sweet little body
trying to trying to absorb that yeah so
like it it
and like fear of judgment let me ask you
a scary thing yeah what does that get
you
because it gives you something what does
it give you
I don't know I don't know if it's a way
to just not deal with what I'm actually
feeling
look at you dude have you been to
counseling before
oh like four different counselors all
right good
um yeah well played so you've you've put
some work in already I could tell
um yeah yeah so it's a good way for your
brain to distract you from reality uh so
what's the reality you need distracted
from
um
[Music]
that you're beautiful
that you're a great wife
that you're a fun friend that you're a
good mom
because you don't feel comfortable when
I say those things do you
not entirely I can feel it on the phone
man I can feel it on you and I'm not
even looking at you why can't you hear
that
I can hear it I just think
um it's hard for me to say out loud to
others like I feel like it's immodest
there you go
and so do you realize that your core
sensor is that this whole thing that
this whole body that you inhabit is
wrong
that it's broken you have to just your
body is distracting you from you
and that is a recipe for hell on Earth
and I'm sorry that your other counselors
didn't tell you that
do me a favor put your hand like open up
your hand and put it um just below your
neck on your chest
okay
say the words out loud
I love this girl
okay was that easy to do is that hard
are you just performing for the show
it was off
I want you to do that 10 times a day in
front of the mirror
here's what you have to make peace with
you have to make peace with you
and I know you called about your
daughter we'll get to your your
daughter's son we'll get to your kid
um
but I live this life that you're talking
about
and it's when I realized that my body
was trying to protect me from what was
going on
and it was sending me signals and so OCD
wasn't a thing to run from it wasn't a
thing to be terrified from and by the
way I have to say say it up front mine's
not debilitating mine's frustrating and
annoying but it's not debilitating like
I don't yeah it's not either I don't
wash my hands till I bleed or anything
like that
um
but I do have to make a bunch of laps
around the house in the evening to make
sure the doors are locked and I do count
I do blink and I I got all my all the
stuff that's fine
here's the deal it's my body trying to
get my attention almost always okay
that's number one so I don't want you to
give up on Nicole
it is not immodest
in fact as far as I'm concerned it is
honoring
the person God created
to tell the truth about yourself
and if you're beautiful and you're a
good mom and you're a great wife not
perfect none of us are
it's dishonest to not say that do not
live into that
okay
and I know that takes work especially
when you've been told by everybody you
know and love and care about that that's
wrong
and that will get you towards your worst
fear which is burning in Hell For
Eternity right
that's number one number two
um I'm gonna be careful about because I
don't want to put my kids stuff out
there too much but I will say I sat down
with one of my kids just about a year
ago
and here's the conversation I had
I have a very special brain
and my brain pays very close attention
to certain things and it is very good at
reading a room
and because it's good at reading a room
I can I I can make people feel
comfortable
and give them some peace
I can also make people feel very
uncomfortable because then I'm not when
I'm not paying attention right
and I told one of my kids you have that
same special brain
and
it's a gift and it's just something that
makes us different and we have to work
through some things that other people
have to work through
and that phrase special brain
because one of my kids was counting a
lot and asked my wife to turn the radio
down because
they were trying to Blink between every
drum beat and they couldn't keep up and
my wife just was like oh good my husband
created another one of him and
um and at the same time I would submit
that it's been a superpower it's really
frustrating to work with me sometimes
right and I think it can be fun too
right so all that to say is this that
phrase special brain
and the phrase I have it too
and the phrase
and so we have some extra work to do
those are your three magic points
okay okay number one there is a genetic
in a neurological basis for OCD period
it just is
end
genes are most often expressed
environmentally something in the world
that they're growing up in sets them off
like a light switch right
and so
if you have parents with OCD you have
parents with ADHD you're probably gonna
have kids with ADHD or you're not
probably you're going to be
statistically more likely to
one because there's a genetic component
and two you've created a household that
has chaos in it right and that's your
body's response to it so
the second thing is is you're gonna let
your kid know you're not alone I'm with
you
and there's something about social
norming especially with kids letting
them know you're not crazy you're just
like me and right now you don't believe
it but you're the most important person
in the whole wide world to this little
kid
and in a weird way they get to be like
Mommy
and the third thing is is it's a context
not an excuse the world will not Bend to
us
so when I need to check the locks three
times before I leave my house or five
times or however many times I need to do
it
I gotta get up earlier because my work
starts at eight o'clock
right the world doesn't Bend to me
you can ask Kelly she does not Bend when
I'm late right
so all I have to say is you're going to
communicate to your kid this isn't a
free pass on the world
right you got some extra work to do
right
but I don't want you
and it's gonna be hard I don't want you
trying to fix her
him him okay
well so okay I have a couple questions
bring them
okay well he's only two so at what point
do I have that conversation with him
what's an age-appropriate what what
behaviors is he already exhibiting okay
well that was
I'm obviously going to be like oh he has
OCD already look at that so I don't know
if I'm over concerned or yes yes yes
um yes so like he's been he'll do stuff
like um closing the doors and and all
none of these things are every time it's
not like every time he sees a door open
he has to close it but he'll for someone
his age it feels a little peculiar to me
like he'll close doors have you ever
been around two-year-olds before
a little bit not a ton okay you don't
really know what peculiar is your kids I
I'd be willing to bet your kid's great
oh no he is great I know he's great he's
fantastic I just don't know if the
behavior is
I don't know if if normal is a word for
a two-year-old
I mean there's there's some way outside
of the bell curve stuff and I also think
as a culture we've gotten so obsessed
with these norming things that were
we've made our kids who are special in
and of themselves
every kid has like a thing right and
right well and he like he'll he'll push
our chairs in when we're done with
dinner and he'll he he will like put his
toys away which I'm not complaining
about that is not that's not that's not
that's not a pathology it's fantastic
but like some people see it and they're
like did you tell him to do that no call
don't put that into the world it doesn't
need to be there
all right you're a good mom you're
raising a good healthy kid and let me
say this here's a trap I don't want you
to fall in please please please please
don't Google diagnose your kid
okay
don't you're gonna make yourself crazy
and you're gonna put you're gonna give
that burden to your kid to Carrie it's
not it's not fair
if you have some legitimate concerns
about your kids psychiatric well-being
or their pediatric well-being great
every parent does
what trained medical professionals are
for
do not make a diagnosis about your kid
okay and in fact you may want to go get
re-diagnosed with OCD and see if that
still even holds true
yeah
well so okay so my question is when he
so when he does stuff like this like
pushing chairs and cleaning his toys up
like doing stuff like that I love to
encourage him to do that but I guess I'm
wondering am I
encouraging an OCD tenancy or should I
just
yeah he's cleaning he's cleaning up
after himself I know he's pushing in
chairs because it's fun
he's accomplishing things he's moving
his body he's pushing up against
resistance and it's moving under his
weight it feels good
okay he's picking up his toys probably
because he saw his OCD mom picking up
everything in her life too
like like there's not what you're
telling me not one single thing
and if
he was in bed
screaming his lungs out
because there was a stuffed animal out
of place
and it was chaotic and snot coming out
of his nose until he got up and moved
the arm just right and then got back
into bed then I would say you probably
need to go talk to somebody
like he's clearly projecting something
out but again he's freaking two he's two
sounds like you got a lovely little kid
he's cleaning up there's just moms All
Over America listening to this going
what
cleans up his toys that's awesome
my son I don't know how this happened my
son will walk in and be like I'm tired
I'm going to bed so I'll feel good
tomorrow
I don't know where he got that from
but he doesn't need to go see somebody
it's just amazing behavior that I'm
really oh I'm encouraged I was like way
to go man I'm glad you honor your body
better than your dad does because your
dad's like I'm tired
I bet I could uh
drink some coffee and stay up later
whatever
then your kids are good
I think the work that needs to be done
here Nicole let's start with let's start
with Nicole
and I think it would be time to go get
re reevaluated okay and sit down with a
psychologist or sit down with a
counselor and say I'm ready to confront
my OCD head-on
and there's some behavioral techniques
there's some therapeutic techniques that
are showing incredible efficacy there's
even some medication that's showing some
incredible incredible efficacy
but I think it's time to tackle it head
on
and what we're going to create is some
peace in your house I'm missing you
building a non-anxious life too
um
oftentimes especially with thought OCD
thought OCD and anxiety really co-mingle
a lot and um takes a pretty
sophisticated practitioner to parse them
apart
um
but I'm going to send you a copy of this
book too because I want you to check it
out you and your husband can read it and
um
I think it might be good to work through
because I think backing out 30 000 feet
and handling some of these peripheral
things might um be a gift to you in the
Long Haul and maybe turn some of these
alarms down
again if your kid does some things that
are
really truly worry you
or as importantly a couple of moms in
your circle that you trust that say hey
is this normal behavior like yeah it's
fine
um please please take your kid to go see
a psychiatrist or go see a child
counselor or doctor ASAP ASAP
if your kids clean up his toys pushing
pushing the chair in good for him it's
amazing it's amazing and I'll say it
again you're a good mom Nicole
very good mom we'll be right back
if you've listened to my show any amount
of time you've definitely heard me talk
about Thorn Thorne is an incredible
supplement company that makes what I
think are the best supplements in the
game I've taken Thorne for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming the next great
thing for all sorts of ailments almost
all of those claims and products are
either lying not good products or just a
waste of your money Thorne is one of the
very few supplement companies that make
Pure Clean tested and backed by science
supplements no fluff no gimmicks no
nonsense Thorn is what I take personally
and it's what I give to my kids and make
no mistake supplements of this quality
cost more than the nonsense you see in
gas stations so I've partnered with
Thorne for an incredible 25 off discount
for our deloni show listeners go to
thorn.com you slash deloni choose what
you want add it to your cart create an
account and when you check out 25 off
will be knocked off of the entire order
and here's the best part that discount
sticks around for Life go to thorn.com
the letter U slash deloni check it out
all right we're back let's go out to
Woodstock Georgia and talk to the mighty
Trevor what's up Trevor
hey how's it going Dr John doing good my
man what's up
uh so my main question here is how do I
ReDiscover my identity and gain
confidence and who I am so I can create
a more peaceful life for my wife and
myself
where'd your identity go
I don't know I lost it along the way
somewhere take me back on the journey
where'd you lose it so I wrote down a
little context you've been taught me at
any point
um so I've always been like a dream
chaser really satisfied for the quote
normal lifestyle
um but over the last five years or so
I've been putting on this Persona to try
and become this badass of a man I
thought I really wanted it to come and
uh you know Harding my heart uh getting
really into self-development
um
I guess it was because that wasn't ever
the kind of person I was I was just like
sensitive hipster music type guy
um but Fitness kind of brought me out of
a a dark time
that into self-development with that
became a trainer but the story really
starts when I ended up in the Navy SEAL
pipeline in 2019.
um because that was like the image I
wanted to become
um but I ended up dropping through
medical discharge but it's tough to
admit but I'm gotten to a point where I
can't admit it I was really just
dropping out I quit yeah
um it's hard dude it's hard but go ahead
go ahead yeah
so it was a pretty rough experience
process just getting out of the Navy
that's a that's a whole other story
um but and I got home just in time for
covid so
that started and then I became a
firefighter shortly after that I was
about three or four months after getting
back
so I didn't really have enough time to
really mentally recover
um because it shattered my ego like all
my hope you know and who I thought I was
becoming just all kind of got shattered
and I just kind of
muscled my way through recruit school
with the fire department and uh I was
there for
a few years before I ended up leaving
that let me let me just you know yeah
who told you
there's there's a running ticker tape
you know what that is like when you
watch the news that little Stock Market
ticker that runs underneath it just all
the time
yeah
so running ticker tape in your life
under the story of your life
that says this guy sucks
who wrote that because you didn't write
that somebody gave that to you
who wrote that
which which time
um I think the biggest one was in Navy
in the Navy separations unit
you were way before that
because here's the thing I have sat
personally
and hung out with Jocko and we've talked
about what guitars we play
so playing music and lifting weights
aren't mutually exclusive
being in the Navy Seals and me being a
dean of students man the first thing
Furthest Thing from being an ABCO good
grief man
those aren't mutually exclusive
that's not the issue here
you think you suck and I want to know
where that story came from
because you chased it with hipster and
clothes and you chased it with music and
then you chased it with muscles and then
you chased it with
um David Goggins fantasies and then you
chased it with fire jumping fantasies
you're running from something what are
you running from
I don't I don't really know
um
I mean I was the youngest of three three
boys and
you know they were really hard on me
growing up I don't know if that's that's
it
I mean we could probably talk for hours
and unpack it here's the deal
like you're not a piece of crap man
and my promise to you is this one
thousand percent if you were in I know
this because I'm friends with them
if you were a Navy SEAL right now
you still would not like Trevor
period
if you and you fantasize about this if
at one of the fire fights you were
involved with if you saw a baby and you
raced in there and got the baby out
because I know you've played that out in
your head before
you would feel good for a minute then
the next day you would not like Trevor
the crappiest thing about accomplishment
as you go with you
yeah
and the crappiest thing about failure is
you go with you right
yeah
so what like let's take the Navy SEAL
experience right
most people wash out because it's
designed for most people to wash out
and as someone who benefits from having
Elite military force out there fighting
on my behalf
a guy they don't even know
I hope most people wash out
because I want those who don't to be you
know I mean
I remember spending some time with Jocko
and I was like
like kind of my thing is like
everybody's a like we're all the same
down at the core right and then I
remember about half hour and I was like
oh no we're different we're different
right and so I want that I'm happy for
that
and what about that experience washing
out weren't you able to go all right man
I found my limit I found the end and
that's awesome I know most men go their
whole life and they never know where
that end is
they never know what they're capable of
and they never know how how far they can
push themselves you found out
so what about that wasn't a celebration
of course you want to be a seal and
there's some disappointment there but
what about going all right I found
a train as hard as I could and this is
how fast I can run a mile I know I now I
know why why is that
I guess it confirmed what I was trying
to disprove in myself that you were some
kind of loser
yeah
where does that story come from
I don't really know
all right so what are you doing now
so I'm in pest control but the next part
of the story is I'm running an online
coaching business and I'm on my last
week full-time job because I've gotten
to a point where I can take it full time
so that's
I'm really trying to dial in
I'm gonna say something really hard
right now and you're not gonna like it
is that fair cool yeah
well let me ask it instead of saying it
do you have somebody who is running so
hard for themselves do you have any
business coaching other people
do I have what any business coaching
other people right now
I mean I'm having some success of course
you are because you know all the right
things to say you're a real smart guy
and you've watched all the videos
yeah that's that's definitely a thought
I've had
let me answer the question I'm calling
well let me answer the question for you
if you don't quit on Trevor the answer
is yes
this last book I wrote about anxiety I
ended up leaving my family for a week
and I went to a hotel and checked in and
had to write myself out and I spent time
in the hotel gym and in front of a
computer 24 hours a day for a week
I went crazy
but I never gave up on myself I didn't
give up on my wife I didn't give up on
my kids
I didn't give up on my community or my
friends or my job I kept going and
sometimes it was one tiny tiny little
step in front of the other but I didn't
quit and so did that disqualify me from
for helping people with emotional mental
health no
because I'm I'm on the same path as
everybody else is in fact it I think it
gives me some empathy and it gives me
some understanding when somebody calls
you and says hey man I don't know which
way to turn you can go dude I know
but you sound like you were dangerously
close to quitting on Trevor
I don't know I feel like this is my
break to really
you know reel it in
I need you to hear me say the world
needs more coaches men need to have
coaches in their life
and this will not solve you
yeah this won't heal you it's probably a
better word
if you get a million dollars worth of
clients this year
in your take-home salary is six hundred
and eighty thousand dollars after taxes
it will not heal you
your dad's not gonna magically pick up
the phone and finally say he's proud of
you your older brother isn't going to
finally say you know what dude we were
pretty hard on you as a kid you're
awesome
if that call hasn't come yet that Call's
not coming
and if it does come only after financial
success it won't feel right
what you have to choose to do is to love
and honor Trevor now
as you enter into this space
so what are what are the steps to do
that
I I don't know you quote unquote
ReDiscover your identity I think you
plant a flag in the ground and then you
reverse engineer it with a bunch of tiny
little actions
so what do I mean by that you don't I
Alex hermosi was here the other day here
at the at the studios and I think he's
the one who who first said this
um
confidence you can't think your way to
confidence you can't just imagine like
I'm going to be confident I can fight
that guy because your body knows no you
can't
or the first the first jab what remember
that Michael Mike Tyson quote
everybody's got a plan to get hit in the
mouth and you're like oh all right yep
that's not confidence that's arrogance
that's that's that's bullheadedness
that's Idiocracy
confidence is
I've trained for five years I've been in
a lot of hard sparring matches
I'm good
I can stand in here
right that's confident and so you get
confidence by a thousand little wins
and in your case you get confidence by
I'm gonna show up for Trevor
not I'm gonna show up for Instagram
muscles
and not I'm gonna have the best well-lit
coaching photos so I can encourage other
men to get other welded coaching photos
and you've taken them haven't you yes
you have
yeah and I'm not gonna sign up from some
other world-class
like
12 people or however many few get
through the system a year
and I'm gonna hate myself that I wasn't
one of the 12. yeah be disappointed man
you went for it
most people are so such cowards they
never go for it
they never go for it you did
it doesn't mean you quit
and I'll say this
I think David Goggins is fun I think the
world needs David Goggins that is not a
recipe for a long healthy life
okay
I have chosen
well that makes me a week week or a
coward or whatever
that one of the hardest paths you can
take
is to every day be a present father
to every day show up in the boring and
mundane and be a present husband
and
to do that to take care of my body and
exercise and to get enough sleep and to
get off my stupid phone all those things
that you know in the self-development
space but you gotta ask yourself why the
Instagram photo because you think it's
going to heal you because it's not
it has to be because Trevor's worth it
yeah that makes sense I'm going to ask
you to do something I just asked another
caller to do that my therapist asked me
to do and it freaked me out
all right
I want you to take your hand and open it
as wide as you can
and put it right in the middle of your
chest
okay
all right did you just Flex just now
when you did that I'm just kidding but
you probably did yeah I know you did I
knew you did I knew it
all right I want you to say out loud
I love this guy
say it one more time
is it true
yeah
how do you love Trevor every day
I just keep going
keep taking steps forward
I'll ask you again because I hope you
realize how terrible that answer was
yeah I do how do you love Trevor every
day
uh
I appreciate his good qualities
I'm bad at this all right I'm gonna give
you a couple of things
here's how I appreciate John deloney
okay
I write down some things that I'm
grateful for
almost every day of my life
what that helps me do is realize I am
just surrounded by blessing even when
things are sideways and hard
I touch my daughter I hold her face when
she lets me
and I look her in the eyes and I let her
know
I'm so grateful that of all the crazy
people in the world God picked me to be
your dad
and you are really really strong
and you are brilliant and you're
beautiful
and she goes
and this morning I came out and my son
was already writing his book because his
parents are nerds and he was working on
something and I started barking at him
about the dogs and the chickens and the
this and what about that and come on man
what about this and then he opened up
somebody sent me some cereal to try out
for a sponsorship and it looked amazing
and I said hey you try this out first
and he opened it up and the bag went
everywhere he just exploded
and I looked at him and I made a face
that I shouldn't have made just I was
disappointed like what are you doing
like anyway
he walked back inside
and I said hey I need to start over the
morning can we start over
he goes what can we start over and he
goes yes
and I wouldn't give him a big hug and I
held it too long and I said good morning
I love you good it's good to see you
and then I went down and worked out and
I did not want to work out today I don't
feel good my recovery was 44. I didn't
feel like it but I went anyway
and then I showed up to work on time
prepared
and I could go on and on that's what I'm
telling you okay
do I want to look good and have muscles
yes
don't my wife just still think I'm
attractive yes am I ever going to be a
Navy SEAL no
do I hang out with a few of them because
it makes me feel cool absolutely yes 100
percent
100 percent
will ever be that no
is that the is that my calling in life
no it's not and I I made peace with that
a long time ago
but making peace does not mean quitting
Making Peace means a love Trevor
I want Trevor any hole okay
so let's start with those few things who
do I want to be
I want to be a dad who's a good guy
I want to be a husband who shows up and
he's present I'm gonna be a great small
business owner which is what you're
going to be doing when you're coaching
full-time
cool I'm gonna reverse engineer that
what do I need to do every day
my my identity becomes a series of
actions what do I need to do every day
to become a great present husband
what do I need to do every day to be a
great present dad
what I need to do today to be a great
small business owner show up for my
clients
start there
wouldn't be a great Community member a
great member of my church a great like
fill in the blank but start there do
those things
and what you're going to find is when
you show up for yourself when you do the
things that you told yourself you were
going to do
that's confidence
confidence is well earned
because at the end of the day you trust
Trevor
when all else fails
Trevor said he was going to work out for
30 days in a row even if he was just
walking around the block Trevor worked
out for 30 days in a row because Trevor
trusts Trevor
that's confidence
confidence is a is a huge Foundation of
made up of a bunch of little bricks of
you doing what you said you're gonna do
and you can look behind you and you got
the proof
you can't think your way to confidence
you can't will your way you can't
manifest confidence you gotta go do
I wish it was different man I wish it
was different we tried it with a
self-esteem movement utter failure
doesn't work
you have to go do but you also got to do
from a place of I've got value and I'm
worth doing it
and you my brother are
hang on the line I'm going to send you
my book also building a non-anxious life
I want you to read it
um I want you and your wife to read it I
want you to go through it together I
think it'll make a big uh big impact on
your life
by the way congratulations for going
through the uh
Navy SEAL tryout process
most men live quiet lives of desperation
you at least went for it proud of you
we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings in
myths we've believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're gonna go with a great Tom Petty
and the Heartbreakers
the best of all time to ever do it songs
called American Girl and it goes like
this
well she was an American Girl raised on
promises she couldn't help thinking that
there was a little more to life
somewhere else after all it was a great
big world with lots of places to run to
and if she had to Die Tryin she had one
little promise she was gonna keep
take it easy make it last all night
she was an American Girl
unlike Kelly
who's just me I'm just kidding you're an
American girl too
you're a Texas girl oh is there a
difference damn right is there is there
better it's better
shots fired America
send your cards and letters to that one
love you guys stay in school don't do
drugs bye
[Music]